asiye Leon St is a serious competitor
both in the compact class and for fellow
VW Group rivals such as the Skoda
Octavia and VW golf wagons our car
review our line hold would take the
spacious Spaniard over any of them the
headlights are nicer the rear lamps
classier and he especially likes the
typical Leon contouring at the rear
let's see what else it has to offer
following the agile Leon SC hatchback
and the 5-door version we now have the
sporty-er st the new edition is a
cross-fertilization of wagon and sports
car jeans a hybrid engineered for fun
and for hauling a family the first thing
for line hold is how agile the e lay on
st is that's partly because of its very
low weight and also the result of its
performance to an engine the suspension
is firm but not too firm Skoda has also
learned from parent VW how to place
every control where you expect it
everything comes intuitively intuitive
al is a stigma we tested the most
powerful gasoline-fueled version with
132 kilowatts
it makes the dash to 100 km/h in just
seven point seven seconds top speed is
200 24 km/h fuel consumption is 5.8
liters for 100 kilometers as ever in
theory at least there's nothing to fault
as regards the exterior LED headlights
are fitted a standard
the beefy looking air inlets underlined
its sporty character
the interior is all high-quality and
functional and there's also a touch
screen monitor included of course the
Leon St also caters to those with plenty
to transport luggage space galore then
if you have prolonged vacations of mind
cargo capacity is always important for a
wagon TSA's writer actor Simon Burr has
come along to help assess the esti he's
married with children a car fan and a
passionate surfers
he definitely has serious cargo
requirements there's plenty of space for
the whole family says today though sea
monster was out on his own putting the
St sporting prowess to the test in the
mountains and he wanted to go surfing
and was amazed to see how easily a
surfboard fitted in the back
you
you can also choose to have an even
firmer suspension that gives you a
harder feel on the road
adding excitement to the curves
noise and in the Leon St has new driver
assists you'd normally only expect from
a formal family car there is a radar
system that keeps your distance on the
highway and will also bring the car to a
complete stop if need be the same
function is also handy in urban traffic
should a pedestrian suddenly wander into
the street Kent well I gotta start from
their dances Auto they've stopped on
from a guitarist and on fire
overall the Leon St is a sensible car
with a sporty character prices in
Germany started sixteen thousand six
hundred euros for the gasoline version
as long as up misty I note was very
impressed with the adaptive dampers
justement he tried out all the available
modes but preferred sports over eco or
comfort and there really is a difference
between settings comfort is more
comfortable and sport really is sporty
the options enable you to make the car
behave just as you want it which adds up
to a great overall package on degaton
replicas and should images be something
of wood
you